the videos that I have created in the
half-hour Haegele series over the last
two years have been pretty laborious
tasks to produce and I've had a lot of
viewers and subscribers and particularly
my patreon backers who wanted to know
how it is that I put them together so
what I thought I would do is create
another video where I would actually
record some of the process as I go
through it and then show it to you in a
very abbreviated form so you can get
some idea of what goes into the
production of these videos and you can
get an idea of what goes into the
production of some of my other videos as
well so as you can imagine the first
step for me at least is researching what
I'm going to talk about you can see me
here in my office I actually recorded
myself just sitting there reading
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit you know
it's a text that I've gone through many
times here I'm making things go a little
bit quicker and it's important every
time that I shoot this that I go back
over the section look at the paragraphs
I also tend to like to look directly at
the German text whenever there's
anything that I think is a little bit
you know puzzling as far as the the
nomenclature anytime that there's a
clear translation decision that's that's
been made so you know what I've done
here is sped things up about 20 times
you can see me sitting here reading
rereading going through all of these
paragraphs and passages sometimes I
actually flip back in the text to try to
refer to anything that was relevant
before the next step in the process for
me is creating PowerPoint slides which
I'm going to use in generating the
videos every one of the little text
boxes that you see on the side as I'm
reading the text is actually a
PowerPoint slide that I've inserted
using the video editing software all of
the breaks in between the video
footage the beginning and the end
that's all PowerPoint slides and so I
have to write them down you see me going
very fast here again I'm sped it up
about 20 times so you can you can
imagine just how long this takes I am
NOT the fastest of typers and I make
frequent errors as well that have to be
gone back over and corrected but when
I'm finished for any given video that
I'm going to shoot I've got you know
anywhere from 10 to 20 slides and I'm
ready to use those for the video
since I'm using my chalkboard in all of
these videos and since I don't have time
as I'm lecturing to write all this stuff
down I try to put as much as I can on
the board before I actually go to film
the video and you can see me I'm
referring to the text you know this
these half-hour Haegele videos are very
intensive as far as the amount of
thinking that has to go into how to
represent things schematically it's
quite a challenge but you can see me
here gradually working out one of the
paragraphs and writing all the stuff
that I'm going to need for that
particular lecture up on the board after
that It's Showtime
I need to set up the camera the lighting
and get myself ready for for filming in
front of the chalkboard again I'm going
to speed this up really quick you see me
put my jacket and go to town you know I
take a little pause before I begin
sometimes I have to do multiple takes
particularly if there's a lot of outside
noise or if I lose my train of thought
which occasionally does happen you can
see that little tiny video camera
recording me up there that's what I use
I use a tripod and a flip cam and some
decent lighting and that's pretty much
it last step as far as video production
is the editing and that is a pretty
laborious process as well there's a lot
of stuff you can see me gradually
working on the video here you're going
to see more and more Clips being added
to it over time I see me right there
adding in some of the slides and now I
have to scroll up and find the
recordings of when I actually read the
text which happened a long time ago and
cut and paste each of those sections you
know adding some features to them if I
need to some sound and things like that
then I build the text itself as you can
see me doing here into each of the
reading sections and then we're getting
close
to being finished there's a bit of
review because as I've learned you can
never check a video enough times to
catch all of the typos and possible
little errors in it that is it that's
the video process if you have any
questions about it go ahead and leave
them in the comments and I'll answer
them there so thanks to everybody for
watching and sharing and commenting on
the videos and thanks in particular to
my patreon supporters